SETH LADD: Sweet.
JOHN MESSERLY: Hey, John
Messerly, working on Web
Components with Sam and Jacob.
JACOB RICHMAN: Hi, I'm Jacob
Richman, another [INAUDIBLE]
up in Seattle, working on
Dart Web Components.
SETH LADD: Thank you
very much, guys,
for taking the time.
I know Web Components is
a pretty big topic.
And so we're going to
skip over the news.
Probably the big thing just
to reiterate for everyone
watching at home is M1
is getting closer.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, that's
really exciting.
I see that Google just pushed
a new update to the spec.
That's good reading to--
I don't know.
I get excited reading
those things.
SETH LADD: Yeah, definitely.
And we've got a lot of breaking
changes coming in,
trying to get in under
the wire under M1.
You can follow all those
at news.dartlang.org.
So lots going on.
But let's go ahead and dive into
the big topic here, Web
Components.
You've read the spec,
JJ, right?
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
And watched the video.
SETH LADD: And watched
the video, awesome.
So is there a way for you to sum
it up in just a few words?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
Well, there are these guys.
And they like object-oriented
programming.
And so they walk around, and
they're classy guys.
So, of course, we need
to have classes.
And they want to subclass
things.
And they're looking at the web
page, and they see elements.
And they're like, well, I
want to subclass that.
And I want encapsulation.
And I want stuff like
well hidden.
And then I want templates.
And then I want to configure
my CSS with variables.
And then you cram it all
together, and you get
something wonderful in the
browser instead of just at the
framework level where every
framework has to implement
their own widgets.
SETH LADD: Perfect.
And I think that's one of the
key points, at least for me,
is that this isn't just
happening in user
space, if you will.
This is happening at
the platform level.
And so let's turn
over to Seattle.
And I'd like to learn how Dart
is actually intersecting with
Web Components.
Because it's my understanding
Dart is language and libraries
and virtual machine.
And then we're coming in with
Web Components, things
happening actually deep
inside the browser.
So I'd like to start off with
learning how did these two
worlds actually intersect?
SAM HOPKINS: I can
talk about that--
make myself be in the picture.
There we go.
So Web Components and the
technology behind it are
language agnostic.
So they should work equally well
in Dart and JavaScript.
They're an entirely declarative
technology, or a
mostly declarative technology.
So in Dart, just as you would be
able to in JavaScript, you
can do something
that looks like
subclassing a DOM element.
So you can generate your own
custom subclasses of divs and
videos and legends,
like this Hangout.
You can add custom Dart behavior
to those, and you can
use our templating tool that is
inspired by the stuff that
comes out of Web Components
to hook up data to your
components.
Anybody else want to speak about
the intersection of Dart
and Web Components?
JJ BEHRENS: One of my favorite
things when I think about Dart
versus Web Components is that
when you look at JavaScript,
there's what?
16 different ways of
implementing object-oriented
programming?
And every framework has its own
approach to subclassing.
And Dart comes along and has
a way to do classes and
subclassing.
And it is the way for all
of Dart programs.
So all Dart programs can
interoperate, because they
understand what a class is.
And Web Components do that at
the browser level for widgets.
So we'll have a way of having
a great calendar widget from
this team interoperate with
the great maps widget from
this other team.
JOHN MESSERLY: And that's
actually why I think it was so
important for us to
do this in Dart.
Because we're already trying
to bring structured web
programming.
That's kind of what we're
doing in Dart.
And we finally have addressed
this idea that you can have
one way of doing object-oriented
programming.
So it seems very natural to--
oh, and the other thing we're
doing, of course, is
improving the DOM.
And it seems very natural to
take those two things together
and say, hey, well if we're
improving the DOM, why can't
you just extend from it, as if
those were just normal Dart
objects, as if it had been
written in Dart.
SETH LADD: So in the Web
Components world, I can now
finally create a subclass of
button, which I think is huge.
And so that's a big point I
want to make sure everyone
understands, is that you have
all these elements today, part
of the normal DOM, dibs, spans,
buttons, paragraphs, et
cetera, and all of the existing
web development
frameworks out there today
always have to wrap a lot of
these elements to provide
extensions and behavior.
In a Web Components world, you
can actually extend the button
and create your own specialized
button.
Is that true?
SAM HOPKINS: Yeah, absolutely.
We should make clear that the
mental model is that you're
creating a Dart subclass.
But because there's this extra
DOM stuff going on, you also
get to attach custom DOM
to your subclass.
So you're subclassing in the
sense of adding Dart behavior.
But you're also subclassing in
a sense of customizing what
happens on the DOM when you
instantiate your fancy button.
You might say that your fancy
button has some extra images
in it and some text.
And those will get encapsulated
just like the
Dart behavior that you've
attached to it gets
encapsulated.
JJ BEHRENS: That's one thing
that I really like, is that
the web has traditionally lacked
a way of encapsulating,
so that if you're going to have
a widget, you have all of
this DOM stuff that's
in the tree.
And you're trying to see the
widget, but all you can see is
a bunch of divs.
And finally, with the shadow
DOM, we could have one tag
that has some semantic meaning
with all the stuff hidden away
in a nice, encapsulated
way inside of it.
[AUDIO LOST]
more beautiful markup.
SETH LADD: So Jacob, JJ just
mentioned the shadow DOM.
Can you tell us what exactly
is this shadow DOM?
Sounds a little bit
nefarious to me.
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah.
So what the shadow DOM is is
when you're creating your own
custom element, they say it's
extending div, you're going to
want to implement how
it's rendered.
And you're going to implement
that just using the same HTML
that you're used to and
ready to create.
But you're going to implement it
in what's called the shadow
DOM for the element.
So this is going to be a DOM
that only you as the component
creator sees.
When someone opens up their Web
Inspector, by default they
won't be distracted by the
non-semantic divs and side
divs that you might be using
to make your component
rendered the way you want it.
JJ BEHRENS: That's huge.
When I first saw the shadow
DOM I thought it was Bob
Nystrom's doing.
SAM HOPKINS: Ah, yes.
SETH LADD: Well, the evil
Bob, his evil twin.
JJ BEHRENS: The evil Bob, where
it was Google's evil
plot to take over the
world and make
web programming easier.
JACOB RICHMAN: And the
interesting thing about the
shadow DOM is this was
technology that actually did
exist in the web platform but
was only used for native
controls, like video controls.
SETH LADD: I was just going
to point that out.
We actually can see real-world
application of this, as you
just mentioned, that if you
embed a video tag into your
page and the player controls,
like play, pause, and the
slider, that's actually
implemented with actual DOM
elements like divs
and spans, right?
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah, exactly.
And it's just in a shadow DOM
that as a user you haven't
been able to see or been
able to manipulate.
But now you'll be able
to have that
same power as a developer.
JJ BEHRENS: So another thing
that I like about the
encapsulation is the boundaries
that Web Components
place around the Web Components
so that they can
have their own CSS.
And the CSS from the outside
doesn't leak in, and the CSS
from the inside doesn't
leak out.
Do you guys want to
talk about that?
JOHN MESSERLY: Sure.
It kind of all goes back to what
we're talking about with
the shadow DOM, which is it
would be really mean if we're
like, hey, here are these
components, but to render them
you have to draw at a
canvas or something.
That would be really hard.
So we say, well, you can
use DOM primitives.
And, of course, once you're
using browser primitives,
well, if you just display dibs
and spans on a page, they're
going to look like
nothing, right?
They're no good without
some styling.
So you need to be able to style
your shadow DOM in such
a way that nobody else
can affect it.
And they call that the--
there's basically an upper
boundary and a lower boundary
that prevents your styles from
leaking to your children and
prevents styles from the page
from leaking into your shadow
DOM unless you want to.
So you can always turn on--
they also give you the power, if
you want to turn on, styles
flowing in, and you
can do that, too.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, and
[INAUDIBLE], and it kind of
goes for events as well, where
if an event generates within,
kind of deep inside the Web
Component, and bubbles up,
it's kind of sanitized so that
the stuff from the inside
doesn't get to the outside.
Do you guys want to
talk about that?
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah.
So you'll just see the event's
firing on your component
instead of firing on the
specific element deep within
your component.
That's what's going
to make sense.
If you're using a fancy input
element, you want to see the
event firing on the fancy
input element.
You don't want to see
it firing on--
SAM HOPKINS: Some random div.
The idea is that the user of
your widget, just like we've
been able to do for 15 years
outside of the web, the user
of your widget should not
be able to tell the
implementation details
by any way.
They can't query for them.
They can't figure it
out with events.
They can't figure it out by
setting crazy styles and
seeing how your widget
changes.
It has to be real
encapsulation.
SETH LADD: It always comes back
to that encapsulation
term, which, as, JJ, you were
saying in the beginning, is a
concept that a lot of other
programming languages
environments have always had.
And now we're bringing
it to the web.
So we've talked about
encapsulating the structure.
And then you can place
that inside the
shadow DOM of an element.
We've talked about encapsulating
the styles using
scope styles sheets so they
don't leak outside.
So now I want to talk about
encapsulating behavior.
We've talked about structure.
We've talked about styles.
But what do Web Components
bring to
encapsulating behavior?
We mentioned Dart.
We mentioned JavaScript.
What can I do now?
What can I have these
elements do?
SAM HOPKINS: Anything
you want.
As far as Dart is concerned, if
you factor out all this DOM
stuff, these are just subclasses
of DOM elements.
They really are.
You get--
JOHN MESSERLY: Fields.
SAM HOPKINS: Huh?
JOHN MESSERLY: You get fields.
SAM HOPKINS: You
can add fields.
You can add methods.
You have all the stuff
that you would
have imagined already.
You have private fields and
public fields and getters and
setters and so forth.
And you will really just write
this like it's a class body
for this element.
And then when you query for it
in the page or for some reason
you get a hold of this fancy
element, you'll be able to
call methods on it or access
its fields and so forth.
SETH LADD: That's so cool.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I remember we
gave a code lab at Google
I/O. And when I looked at
the code, it was kind of
interesting.
Because you guys were
structuring it in such a way
where you would hide the
DOM stuff inside of it.
And then you would expose these
methods, such as if you
have a stopwatch widget, then
you would have a method that
would say start timing.
And so I'm excited about the
fact that Web Components are
going to give us the same thing,
where we have a list of
methods that these are the
official approved ways of
interacting with this
Web Component.
SETH LADD: And we
should say that
sometimes it might be methods.
Other times it might be setting
attributes or creating
subelements inside your
custom element.
Through your work with working
with Web Components so far,
have you seen any--
I don't know, maybe
it's too early--
design patterns emerge?
Or what seems to be the flavor
of the day in terms of how you
might actually interact with
these Web Components?
Or is it too early to tell?
SAM HOPKINS: You want
to talk about it?
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, I
can say something.
It is pretty early to tell.
But there's definitely some
patterns where you're using
attributes.
So if you have properties
that can be expressed as
attributes, it's really nice.
Because in your HTML page on
your element, you can just
write your attribute.
You can easily data bind it.
We haven't talked about the data
binding yet, so maybe I'm
jumping ahead a little bit.
But it'll interoperate better
between Dart and JavaScript.
So we know we can make
attributes work really well.
So that's definitely one
pattern we've seen.
SETH LADD: But let's actually
talk about that for a second.
Because I want to make sure
everyone understands what
we're talking about.
So we've talked about these
kinds of components.
And you can create them, put
them on your page, and even
interact with them
programmatically, or set
attributes.
And so can you give an example
of a case where setting the
attributes is more or less
equivalent to calling a method
on the component?
JACOB RICHMAN: Suppose you
had a component that was
a Google Maps map.
And so you have an attribute
that's latitude and longitude.
Now set the attribute,
the position of
the map will change.
SAM HOPKINS: And we should be
clear that when you're writing
a Web Component, all the
plumbing to make this happen
is abstracted away for you.
So when you write a Web
Component, you'll implement
some method, like attribute
changed or
something like that.
And eventually the browser, or
for now our polyfill runtime
system will just call that
method for you whenever your
attribute has changed, and you
can handle that appropriately.
So you don't have to worry
about mutation events and
observation and all
this business.
It just all works.
SETH LADD: Cool.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
SETH LADD: And before we get to
that, because you're kind
of leading towards how do we
actually all make this work in
today's world, first, how
do you package these Web
Components, at least what
the spec is saying?
What do these things
really look like?
What are the tangible assets?
SAM HOPKINS: Can we do a demo?
JACOB RICHMAN: Yeah,
let's do a demo.
SAM HOPKINS: Let's do a demo.
Give us two seconds to get
the screen sharing up.
JJ BEHRENS: But you're not
allowed to spend any more time
than it took us to actually
get the show live today.
SAM HOPKINS: So we've
got about half an
hour, is that right?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, we're really
sorry about that, guys.
We had some audio issues.
SAM HOPKINS: All right.
So I think this is
the one I want.
Screensharing working?
Everything happy?
SETH LADD: Looks great.
SAM HOPKINS: Awesome.
So I don't know if I'm
going to do MVC.
It's a little app that people
write in their various
different frameworks to
demo what code looks
like in that framework.
So it's a to-do list app.
I'm going to close the Web
Inspector here so we can play
with it a little bit.
It's a to-do list app.
We can add to-dos.
Today the web, tomorrow
the world.
And I can mark them done,
remove them--
SETH LADD: So awesome.
SAM HOPKINS: --stuff
like that.
So not a super exciting app,
but it's a good way to demo
what stuff looks like in the
Web Components world.
So let's pull up
the Inspector.
And let's first look at a
super simple component.
So you see this little photo
down here that just has some
text in it, double click
to edit a to-do.
So I've made this a component.
And I should preface this
by saying that it's not
necessarily the case that you
would want to make something
at that small level
of granularity
component in a real app.
But it's a nice way to demo
how these suckers work.
So down here in the Inspector,
you can see this div is x
to-do footer.
Another note is that we're
not totally settled
on the final syntax.
So you will probably actually
have a tag that says, x to-do
footer, instead of
this div syntax.
But the semantics
are the same.
So you can see this div is
equals x to-do footer, which
we can't open up.
We can't see anything
below it.
What actually is below
it is a shadow root.
And we will be able to turn on
an extension in a minute that
lets us actually see the
shadow DOM down there.
But what's actually below it is
just some paragraph tags.
So let's look at the
code for that.
Let me share a different thing
really quickly, one sec.
Actually, it's the same thing.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
OK.
So again, this is another place
where the syntax is all
kind of in flux, but the
semantics is not likely to
change all that much.
SETH LADD: I'm sorry,
Sam, what are we
looking at right here?
What file is this?
SAM HOPKINS: How should
say this?
This is a source file that
doesn't actually go through
any existing compiler yet,
compiler that will exist
pretty soon.
SETH LADD: But moving one level
up, what we're looking
at here is actually
a component.
It that true?
SAM HOPKINS: Yeah.
So let me highlight.
What we're looking at, what's
highlighted, is the source for
that footer component.
So you see, we have this element
tag that allows you to
declare a DOM subclass.
And this component doesn't
have any Dart behavior.
We're just talking about the
DOM subclassing stuff here.
So I can tell the system
what tag I'm extending.
I can tell it what the name
of my custom element is. .
And then I can add
some custom DOMs.
So remember that double
click to edit a to-do
line that we saw?
There it is.
It's this DOM that
gets injected
inside the custom div.
Does that make some sense?
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
SAM HOPKINS: Awesome.
So that's how the DOM
subclassing part of it works.
Let's look at a slightly more
complicated one, with some
Dart behavior.
So if we open up the
actual app here--
oh, I can't open beneath but
the to-do list, because the
extension's not on.
That's OK.
So here's the--
JJ BEHRENS: I'm sorry.
You said something about
an extension.
You want to mention just a
little bit more about that?
SAM HOPKINS: Yeah.
I'm using a laptop that's not
mine, which is why this is a
little bit iffy.
There's an extension to the
Web Inspector that you can
turn on for development purposes
that lets you look at
what's in the shadow DOM.
JOHN MESSERLY: So imagine
if you could look
inside your video tag.
SAM HOPKINS: Right, exactly.
But for now, we can
work without it.
So here's the actual to-do
list component,
which is a big thing.
It actually wraps some other
components inside it.
And we have a couple of
different design patterns for
how to do that.
And we'll look at another
example of it in a bit.
Sorry, that was the wrong tab.
So let's look at the to-do
list component.
So here it starts now at
the top of the page.
We have this element
that extends div.
The name is to-do
list component.
And here's some fancier features
that happen in here.
So you see in these template
tags, like before, we've got
the custom DOM that's
in this element.
So it's got an input,
and it's got a list,
and it's got a footer.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, I love that.
How many times have I wanted
to have a style tag
that was just for--
SAM HOPKINS: So check
this thing out.
So this is how we do this
scoping the CSS business.
So this style scopes tag makes
it so that the CSS declared
inside will only apply
inside this widget.
It doesn't leak outside the
widget, which is super cool.
This allows us to just
set the footer font.
In this case, we're using for
something fairly silly, but
it's a good demo.
But here's the cool part.
And again, as I said, the syntax
is in a little bit of a
flux, but the semantics
are the same.
So here's a class body inside
this script tag.
And I can't actually put
the whole thing on the
screen right now.
And this class body contains
the fields methods and so
forth that get attached to
the to-do list element.
So you can see I have this add
to-do method that gets passed
to to-do, which is some other
object I've defined elsewhere
that just encapsulates
the information about
a particular to-do.
And when you add a to-do, the
widget will create a new to-do
list element.
It'll bind the data to it.
And we'll talk about how to do
that automatically later.
And then it'll add it
to its own DOM.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm a little
bit confused.
It says, script type application
slash JavaScript.
But I see types.
So it looks like Dart.
Can you tell me--
SAM HOPKINS: Right.
So remember how I said this is
a source file that doesn't go
through any compiler
right now?
We haven't actually been
able to check it.
That's an error.
That should say application
Dart.
I apologize.
Or it may--
I don't know if you know,
Jacob, what the current
version of the syntax is.
That script tag may not
actually exist.
It may be in a separate file.
JACOB RICHMAN: No, you could
write it like that.
We could look at the
syntax, the version
that's currently there.
SAM HOPKINS: OK, well, in a
minute, we'll look at one that
actually runs through the
compiler as it exists.
Sorry for the slight
disjointedness here.
SETH LADD: That's OK.
SAM HOPKINS: So hopefully this
gives you an idea of how these
suckers work.
Let me find--
OK, so here's one other piece.
There's these lifecycle methods
that you can subscribe
to that will be called
on your component at
the appropriate times.
So here's this created method
that I have that I'm never
actually calling in my code.
But the runtime system knows
when I've created one of these
components, and it'll call this
created method for me.
And it allows me to set up
some fields and so forth.
It acts a little bit like a
constructor, except it doesn't
actually do the construction
itself.
Again, there's this inserted
method that gets called when
the component is inserted into
the main DOM that allows me to
set up event listeners
and so forth.
And you can see, I haven't
actually done
anything with them.
But there's these other
lifecycle methods, in
particular, the attribute
changed one that we were
talking about, that'll just
automatically get called when
one of your attributes
gets changed.
SETH LADD: This is great.
So we see an element tag here
that encapsulates, quite
literally, actually, the
structure of the new element--
we saw that there--
the style of the element,
and then the
behavior of the element.
And it's all one self-contained
package.
That's really cool.
JJ BEHRENS: So I assume these
components can call each
other's methods?
SAM HOPKINS: Absolutely,
especially when you're in an
all-Dart universe.
And we can talk about the
inner operation later.
But if I query for one of these
guys on my page and then
I have a reference to it, and
I just call one of its
methods, it'll work as
you would expect.
So as long as one component can
get a reference to another
component, it just treats
it as a Dart object.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
SAM HOPKINS: Do you guys
want to launch into--
let me turn off the
screenshare here
so you can see us.
There we go.
Hi, again.
SETH LADD: Great.
So this might be a
good transition.
We saw the demo to-do
app, which is cool.
And then we saw the
code behind it.
And that showed us the examples
of encapsulation,
behavior, and all
that good stuff.
But now I'm kind of curious.
Well, that was Dart code.
And Dart doesn't actually run in
production browsers today.
In fact, Web Components is very
much a set of standards
being born as we speak.
So how do you guys take all
these new technologies and
techniques and actually make
them available today?
What's your secret?
JOHN MESSERLY: Our secret for
Dart, we have Dart to JS.
And that's our compiler text
Dart code to JavaScript.
Everyone who's listening is
probably familiar with that.
The other thing that
we're building--
SAM HOPKINS: Screenshare.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah,
how do I do that?
SAM HOPKINS: What do
you want to demo?
JOHN MESSERLY: Do you want
to show this one?
SAM HOPKINS: You just do
screenshare, and then you do--
JOHN MESSERLY: Actually, the
Dart editor first, if you can.
JACOB RICHMAN: You might just
give them a-- screenshare the
whole screen.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, can you
screenshare the whole screen?
SAM HOPKINS: Yeah.
Screensharing the
whole screen.
JJ BEHRENS: Don't
leak anything.
JOHN MESSERLY: We'll leak
our open source
Web Component secrets.
SAM HOPKINS: I'm going to have
to biggify the font.
JOHN MESSERLY: Oh,
you're right.
JJ BEHRENS: It's not nearly as
exciting in the Chrome world
as it is in the Android world.
JOHN MESSERLY: What?
The leaking options?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, leaking.
SAM HOPKINS: Yeah, that's the
thing about six-week releases.
How's the font size?
Can you guys read that?
SETH LADD: A little bit.
If you can make it
bigger, great.
But I think that's as
big as it gets.
JOHN MESSERLY: So what we're
looking at here, this is a
version that's actually
running.
And the way that we--
this is a similar version of the
app that Sam showed you.
But what's interesting about
this one is that we actually
have a compiler now
that can look at--
so this is our--
to run in browsers that
aren't going to--
like potentially versions of
IE that aren't going to get
native Web Components for
a while, they're very
excited about it.
They're on a different timeline
than we're used to on
Chrome and Firefox and Safari.
So what we want to do is
basically the same strategy
we're using for Dart.
We're going to make a really
good compiler that's going to
take these input files with
elements and templates and all
this great stuff and generate
a combination of HTML pages
and Dart files to back that.
And then eventually then
the Dart is compiled to
JavaScript.
So you end up with a set of
files that can just run in
existing browsers.
So I'm going to show
you how that works.
It's pretty simple.
We basically have a--
SAM HOPKINS: You want
to biggify the--
JOHN MESSERLY: Oh,
yeah, I should.
SAM HOPKINS: Just Alt-plus
should--
or Command-Plus should
do it, right?
JOHN MESSERLY: Good call.
SAM HOPKINS: More
"embiggening."
JACOB RICHMAN: More bigger.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, we
basically have this project on
GitHub, which will be a package
on Pub as soon as Pub
is ready for us to put it up
there and we get a little bit
further along.
But basically, it's GitHub.
It's under Dartlang and then
Dart Web Components.
That's the name.
And we have this little
compiler for Dart Web
components, which you
can just run.
So I'm going to run it on that
file I just showed you, that
template tool main HTML.
So it's pretty fast,
as you can see.
And it basically scanned all of
our HTML files and it picks
them apart and creates HTML
that will work in existing
browsers and Dart code, which
then you can either run
directly in Dartium or you
can run in Dart to JS.
I don't have it set up at the
moment to run it through Dart
to JS, but it's normal
Dart code.
So there's no magic to
that second step.
SETH LADD: I'm sorry, John.
Just so I'm clear, what you
just compiled was not into
JavaScript.
Is this just split in between?
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
It's a two-step process.
Because we already have the Dart
to JavaScript compiler,
which is working great.
So the first step is basically
to do a few things.
So we want to implement
this data binding.
We haven't talked as
much about this.
But this is another important
part of their overall Web
Component story, which is some
folks on our Chrome Web
Standards team looked at this
proliferation of JavaScript
frameworks.
And they're like, what are
these common elements?
Because everyone has to
keep reinventing this.
And they don't interoperate
with each other.
And people can't easily share
code that's written in these
different frameworks.
And one of the common features
was components.
So we've talked a
lot about that.
The other one was data
binding, some
kind of easy way to--
I've just got a field here, and
it's a string, and I want
to make it show up in my text.
Or I've got the onBlur event,
and I just wanted to call my
Dart method.
So it's a set of things
that we do.
So when we run our compiler,
we have a few things.
We have to process these
template element tags and
admit the right code to
construct the Dart object at
run time and bind it to the
element on the JavaScript DOM.
And then we also have to
generate code to handle all
these little expressions and to
do the right data binding.
So those are essentially the
things that compiler does.
I can show you.
The output is kind of
ugly right now.
We need to make it
more pretty.
SETH LADD: Sure.
But the idea is then you run
this Dart to JS so that it can
work in today's modern
browsers.
JOHN MESSERLY: Exactly.
JJ BEHRENS: And I assume one
of these days we might have
some integration with the Dart
editors so that this stuff is
kind of automatic.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yes.
In fact--
SAM HOPKINS: It's coming.
JOHN MESSERLY: We're getting
close to it.
Many of these things
are different
things going in parallel.
So one of the things we have
been looking-- oh, this is
going to look small again.
Well, the important part is
we're basically looking at a
way that you can have this
file down here, which is
build.dart, which is a special
file you put in your--
the editor landed support for
this pretty recently.
It's a special file you put in
the root directory of your
project, and they know to call
that when files change.
And that means that we can then
handle the template tool
automatically.
So you edit one of these
component files.
So I go up here to my footer,
and I edit something.
I change some text here,
and I save it.
And then immediately, they'll
generate the new version.
So I go to my browser
and refresh--
actually, in fact I may
only need to go to
the browser and refresh.
And it will just know to
compile it on the fly.
It's going to be a pretty
sweet story.
SETH LADD: Yeah, the feedback
we get is that the editing
experience in the Dart world
is really fantastic.
Because you sit in the editor,
and you run the application
which spits out Dartium,
which is just Chromium
with the Dart VM.
And you get that great, make a
little change, hit reload.
And it's cool to see you guys
trying to emulate that and
make that work as well.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm addicted
to that.
I have to have that.
SETH LADD: So those
are great demos.
And it looks like we're on
track to make the future
happen really, really soon.
And that is the part that
really excites me.
Talk to me a little bit about
who else is supporting this
whole idea of Web-- is this
a Chrome-only thing?
Is this a Google thing?
Where is this coming from?
JOHN MESSERLY: Well, a lot of
the work has been driven by
some of our open standards
folks at Google.
But there's a lot of excitement
from especially
Firefox and IE.
So the people who are behind our
web standards, they meet
very frequently with
those guys.
Mozilla has done a project
called X-Tags, which if you
search for "Mozilla X-Tag"
you can easily find it.
That's the part of it where
you can put x dash John's
fancy button on your page and
it will know to instantiate
the Dart or JavaScript object
that's backing that.
SAM HOPKINS: We have that.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah,
we have that, too.
SETH LADD: Cool to see how their
browsers also try to
make this whole vision.
SAM HOPKINS: We should
note that the--
I believe, X-Tags project was a
JavaScript polyfill, right?
So you can also just last week
or maybe two weeks ago, there
was a patch that went up on
Mozilla.org to implement the
beginnings of custom element
support right in the C++, in
the parser and the rendering
engine and so forth.
Because it's a standard that's
in progress, there's lots of
different proposed APIs, and
they're implementing one
that's a little bit different
from the way Chrome was
talking about implementing it.
But it's the same semantics.
And eventually, we will converge
on the way this will
work for all browsers.
But they've got a patch.
It's going to happen
in Firefox.
JJ BEHRENS: I love the
term polyfill.
Not everyone understands, but
to define polyfill, polyfill
is this bit of magic that
makes tomorrow's
web available today.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
And I think what the team was
showing off earlier are
compiler step.
Let's take advantage of that.
Let's make that work for us and
translate a world in the
more pure Web Components world
back down into the existing
tech we have today.
And so I'm interested.
I'm sold.
What's the status
of the project?
And can I use this today?
And how can I follow along?
JOHN MESSERLY: Following
along is easy.
I would say go to our GitHub
project and just watch it.
And you can watch what's
going on there.
SETH LADD: And is the sample
we saw also in
GitHub, the to-do MVC?
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
There are two versions
right now.
We're still working
on merging them.
We have our compiler and our
version that just runs in
Dartium with no need
for a compiler
or a server or anything.
It just runs in the client.
So those two versions, right now
they have some very small
differences.
So we're working on
merging it now.
As soon as we get that, I think
we'll have a pretty good
place where people can start
using it to build components
and see what it feels like.
So I would say it's coming
pretty soon.
SETH LADD: Good to know we can
follow it along in open source
and try it out and
send feedback.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
And listen to the Dart mailing
list as well for anyone who's
not subscribed to that.
Because we will definitely be
sending some news there when
we're at the point where, hey,
we need a lot more people to
try this, because it's
gotten solid.
SAM HOPKINS: And I think the
plan is that parts of this are
going to roll out
of piecewise.
So I think you'll be able to
play with the template
compiler before you'll be able
to interact with components.
You'll need to start by just
doing your interaction with
components via the template
compiler.
And you won't be able to do it
in Dart code that doesn't run
through that compiler.
And eventually, hopefully,
you'll just be able to write
any old Dart code that can query
for an element on a page
and do something with it.
Stuff is going to roll out
piecewise as we develop the
necessary code and
infrastructure.
SETH LADD: That totally works.
That allows us to be a little
bit more responsive to
feedback, too.
SAM HOPKINS: Exactly.
SETH LADD: Great.
Well, hopefully, we've got some
time for some questions.
I don't know if we'll hit every
one, but there are some
very highly voted questions
for you guys.
So JJ is going to
fire them out.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I don't think
we're going to get to
every question, because there's
four pages of them.
SETH LADD: That's good.
People are very interested.
I like it.
JJ BEHRENS: So Ravendra from
Bangalore said, "What are the
list of Web Components targeted
for the M1 release?
Will there be a data binding,
for example, list views for
dynamic data?"
JOHN MESSERLY: That's
a great question.
Where we are right now is we're
laying this foundational
layer that makes it possible
to build on this.
I think after that it makes a
lot of sense to start building
out some base widgets and
other things like that.
I think we'll have more to
say about that soon.
But right now, we're still
focusing on just enabling
components to work well
in the browser.
SAM HOPKINS: I believe, though,
that one of the
versions that you've already
seen that we demoed uses a
very prototype dynamic
list component.
So we won't necessarily endorse
any particular list
component yet as this is the Web
Components list component.
But you can see how you might
go about writing one if you
look at that demo.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, that's
a great point.
There will definitely be
data binding on lists.
So if you're mainly looking to
data bind and say here's my
list of Dart model objects, I
want to bind these two to
individual rows in a list,
something along those lines,
you'll definitely be
able to do that.
SETH LADD: I'll make a plug
for Pub here as well.
I can see Pub, our package
manager, also being a
mechanism to discover and
distribute Web Components
themselves.
And so you might find lots
of different list binding
components out there.
So that's pretty cool.
JJ BEHRENS: So next up, I think
we've partially answered
this, but maybe you guys could
refresh our memory Ernesto
from Granada, Spain, said,
"Web Components is a
technology that's still finding
its way to build
things and requires additional
flags in the stable Chrome not
fully supported at all
in other browsers.
How will we interact with that?"
So we talked a little
bit about polyfills.
SETH LADD: I think we
answered this one.
That's what makes me so excited
is we can actually try
this stuff today, hands-on
experience with this
technology in today's
browsers.
Love it.
JJ BEHRENS: Polyfill magic.
JOHN MESSERLY: I will just throw
out one other comment,
which is I think that one
thing that has actually
surprised me a little bit
working on this project is
that it seems like the web is
starting to move a lot faster.
And I think there's a lot that
Firefox and Safari are on very
fast updates.
And IE really wants to
see a programming
model improve, too.
So things are coming faster than
you might think if you're
used to the pace that the
web used to be at.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
I don't know about you guys,
but as soon as I wake up in
the morning, I look to see
what's been committed to
Chrome the night before.
SETH LADD: That's why we
have Peter Beverloo.
JJ BEHRENS: So Pablo says,
In the UI lid, you
have a widget hierarchy.
For example, panel class extends
to component class and
the window class extends
to panel class.
That way, you can reuse
components and
decrease the code size.
Is it possible do the same with
Web Components, ie., can
Web Components subclass
themselves?"
SAM HOPKINS: Absolutely.
JJ BEHRENS: OK, good.
I was afraid you were going to
say that they could only
extend existing things.
SAM HOPKINS: Oh, no, no.
JOHN MESSERLY: That
would be no good.
SETH LADD: Not on my watch.
JJ BEHRENS: He says, "Can I use
a Dart Web Component with
a JavaScript Web Component?"
SETH LADD: That is he.
I am him.
That was my question.
JJ BEHRENS: The answer to
that is, absolutely.
SETH LADD: I kind of want
to hear a little
bit more about this.
And we touched on it a little
bit when we were talking about
attributes versus methods.
But can you guys give a couple
words on what the interops
story between these components
would be, JavaScript, Dart,
vice versa?
JACOB RICHMAN: Today if you used
attributes, you're good.
In the future, you'll be able to
invoke methods as well, but
that part of the story is a
part that we aren't really
ready to really say is ready
for public consumption.
But the nice thing about Web
Components is you've got an
object that makes sense to talk
about referencing from
both Dart and JavaScript in a
way that you don't really
have, talking about just an
arbitrary object in the Dart,
either for JavaScript
or [INAUDIBLE].
Because in both Dart and
JavaScript, you've got a
concept of what an element is.
SAM HOPKINS: And
discoverability is easy, right?
A way for the thing from either
Dart or JavaScript.
But we so we believe that a
large amount of the APIs on
these things can be implemented
just using
attributes.
And any API with its attributes
is really easy.
You just set the attribute
from JavaScript or Dart.
And the other side, Dart or
JavaScript, can pick up that
attribute change and respond
accordingly.
SETH LADD: I'd like to really
make a personal plug towards
that type of a design,
let alone interop.
I think at least when we're
talking about components in,
as Sam, you like to call it, the
declarative renaissance of
web development, which,
I love that term.
To me, the key one there
is declarative, right?
It's declaring the elements.
They might have attributes.
They may have their
own subchildren.
And at least I'd like to see us
make an effort on designing
APIs that way and see
what happens.
JJ BEHRENS: So the next
one is from an Antaro.
"Can you explain to C Sharp and
Java developers before you
go into detail as to what Web
Components are?" Now, I know
that we've already covered what
Web Components are, but
can we take another Java
C Sharp spin on this?
No, I'm just joking.
Let's move on.
Vadam from Russia.
"Having watched some
presentations about Angular
JS, it looks that Angular and
Web Components have very
similar central ideas.
What is the relationship between
these two projects,
and what is the difference
between them?" I think it's
really about which cafeterias
we prefer.
SETH LADD: You guys have
any thoughts on that?
I know by Angular JS is mostly
a Google project.
SAM HOPKINS: The key is that
these are going to be part of
the web platform.
Angular JS is a great framework,
but it's one among
many frameworks.
And it has all the same
problems in terms of
interoperating with other
frameworks, being written in
JavaScript and not natively in
the browser, and so forth.
And in a future coming to you,
Web Components will be part of
the browser and part of
the web ecosystem.
JJ BEHRENS: I would say that
this Web Components idea is a
lot more ambitious then Angular
JS, whereas Angular JS
works really solidly for a lot
of apps already today in
production.
SETH LADD: So let's
take three more.
I like these two questions.
JJ BEHRENS: "Can you give one
or a few examples of how to
use--"
SETH LADD: We definitely
did that.
Let's skip to this one.
[?
JJ BEHRENS: Gundmund said,
"What are the performance
implications of using
Web Components?"
That's a good one.
SETH LADD: Well, there's a lot
of different ways to look at
performance--
raw computation, initial load
times, loads from cash.
JJ BEHRENS: It's all
about latency.
SETH LADD: The latency.
But what I heard today was we
have a compilation step.
And so we can do really smart
things to help our
performance--
early binding, late binding,
minification, taking advantage
of particular platform
capabilities that might exist
for your browser.
So I don't know what you guys
think, but I'm hoping that in
terms of performance, if you
were to write this with your
declarative capabilities today,
and you were to write
this with Web Components, the
performance should be
basically the same, right?
JOHN MESSERLY: That's
exactly right.
SAM HOPKINS: One of the design
goals for the way that we
implement all this
functionality--
and we're still in design and
prototyping phase for the
final implementation of all
this-- is that they cannot
have any performance cost above
standard view model
frameworks or even
just standard
hand-coded view model stuff.
JJ BEHRENS: The next question
is, "What would be the role of
Web Components in developing
games with Dart?" Let me try
to take a stab at that one.
SETH LADD: Go for it.
JJ BEHRENS: If you've coded
games in JavaScript, obviously
you have the option of whether
you want to stick with just
functions and closures
or you want to put
together an OOP system.
And I think that the same thing
kind of goes for Dart.
And the same thing also goes
for Web Components, in that
Web Components allow you to
structure your app in a way
that might be helpful,
especially for a larger app.
What do you guys think?
JACOB RICHMAN: I'd say for a
game, you're going to use Web
Components for the
UI of your game.
But for the actual main rendered
game area, Web
Components aren't going
to really impact
your life that much.
You're going to be using Web
TL or Canvas directly.
JJ BEHRENS: So I'm going to
create a new term here--
PODO--
Plain Old Dart Objects--
all the way down.
Gundmund also asks, "How is
model-driven views related to
Web Components?
How is Outlook browser
support for MDVs?"
SETH LADD: This is a good
one to end on, yeah.
MDV and Web Components.
Is that the same thing?
Are they two buzzwords
of the same flavor?
What's the difference?
JACOB RICHMAN: They are two
pieces that we think together
really form a compelling story
for how you create your MVC
apps in Dart.
The two pieces are designed
to be pretty separable.
So a user who really likes Web
Components but doesn't really
like MDV can still go ahead
and live in that world.
SAM HOPKINS: Just so we're
clear, MDV is another name for
the data binding stuff that
we already showed off.
SETH LADD: MDV is
model-drive use.
JACOB RICHMAN: So MDV's how you
really closely define how
you're binding your plain old
Dart data objects of your
model to your UI of your view.
SETH LADD: And I think one of
the design considerations
around MDV is that it should
feel very webby.
So you might have data
in the forms of ULs
and LIs on your page.
And you might say, that is my
model, which I really love.
Because then as you get more
declarative with these sorts
of things, you can play off of
what makes the web so great
today, which is crawlability,
indexability.
And I believe one of MDVs
design constraints or
philosophies is maintain
this crawlability,
indexability behavior.
JACOB RICHMAN: You'll define
your templates for your views
with standard HTML.
But your model will
be Dart code.
Your model will be Dart
lists and maps.
SETH LADD: Can you have models
that are also in the page like
JSON objects or actual
HTML objects?
Maybe this is an old version
of the spec.
JACOB RICHMAN: No, your models
would be [INAUDIBLE]
classes.
You're not going to force
yourself to represent your
model as XML instead of--
SETH LADD: Oh, hopefully not.
JJ BEHRENS: So guys, I want to
thank you guys for taking the
time to meet with us.
This was a lot of fun.
I know that a lot of us are
looking forward to this Web
Components stuff.
And I think this is going to
lead to a nicer the feature of
web development.
SETH LADD: And thank you very
much to Sam, who I know made a
special trip back to Seattle
Google office.
So I appreciate that, for
showing us what you've been up
to all summer.
And so on behalf of the whole
Dart community, we thank
everyone there for working out
in the open, especially on
this project.
I should probably remind
everyone watching that we've
got an open mailing
list and open bug
tracker, open issue tracker.
This an open source project.
We definitely love
the feedback.
We've made numerous changes
based on feedback on Dart.
And we look forward to people
trying out Dart Web
Components.
And I think it's going
to be big.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
OK, well until next time,
take care of yourselves.
SETH LADD: Thanks, everybody.
See you next time.
Bye.